Speaker 1: All right, so former President Donald
Trump was interviewed in an it can't even really
be called an interview, it was really sort of
a softball propaganda piece. It was it was soft
propaganda that Trump and Fox News host Sean
Hannity did together. The big headline from
this interview was that Donald Trump said
the Haitian immigrants are bringing AIDS
into the United States, and some people
wrote to me and they said, You know, David,
there's a lot of aids in Haiti, in Haiti. And so
we have to we have to consider that let's let's
look at the clip and then we'll talk about it
here. Is Trump explaining it all to Sean Hannity?
Speaker 5: And you know, there's one other
thing that nobody talks about. So we have
hundreds of thousands of people flowing in from
Haiti. Haiti has a tremendous AIDS problem.
AIDS is a step beyond. AIDS is a real bad
problem. So hundreds of thousands of people
are coming into our country. And then if you
look at the stats, if you look at the numbers,
if you look at just take a look at what's
happening in Haiti, a tremendous problem with
AIDS. Many of those people will probably have AIDS
and they're coming into our country and we don't
do anything about it. We let everybody come in.
Speaker 1: So first of all, I was not able to
find any reporting that hundreds of
thousands of Haitians are coming in.
I just I just was not able to find evidence
of that. It is true that there is a
higher rate of aids in Haiti than in many
other countries. That's absolutely true.
Its relevance in terms of what's going
on with immigration, particularly
when it is not a virulently contagious disease
like COVID, although certainly more serious.
It's just weird to make that the focus again
unless you just want to portray a population as
dirty, unclean, sick and infected, which is like a
classic of authoritarians towards minority groups,
that that's really what it is. If you really want
to have a public health sort of conversation about
migration that can be done. That's not what
Donald Trump is is trying to do here. Check
out this next segment. This is a segment that
starts with Hannity asking Trump a question,
but then he sort of gives the answer. And
it's really weird. Like where? Where does
the question end and the propaganda begin?
Speaker 3: You know you, you were last time on
this program, and I think we need to put emphasis
back on this, that your conversation with the
leader of the Taliban before you ever discussed
any deal of withdrawal was number one and was
based on your your stated threat that you would
obliterate them. Do you remember exactly what you
said? Because I have a source that says you were
brutal to that and that you said you would destroy
them, you would destroy their province, you would
destroy it, and it would be everybody in the area
would be dead. Did you say that everybody?
Speaker 5: So what I said and I had a very
strong conversation. I said, I hate to start the
conversation this way, but that's the way it is.
And I said we would do serious, serious
harm to them if they killed any of our
soldiers or any American citizen. So really,
Speaker 1: Hannity kind of handling the
question and answer for the most part there.
Trump then added this. This is just amazing.
Trump talks about vaccination and how a
lot of people now don't want the vaccine.
I can't tell if Trump is this stupid or if this
is deliberate, Trump says. When I was president,
everybody wanted the vaccine. Now that Biden's
president, a lot of people don't, as if that's
something that makes Trump look good.
Speaker 5: Well, you know, I was saying
the other day is very interesting. During my
administration, everybody wanted the vaccine,
right? Nobody saying, Oh, gee, I don't
want to take it. Now they say that,
and that's because they don't trust the Biden
administration. I can think of no other reason,
but they say, we don't want it. We aren't going
to take it. When I was there, everybody wanted
it and we were doing great with it.
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, you know,
so let me let me translate that for you. What
he means is under under me. My followers wanted
the vaccine because they thought I made the
vaccine and left wingers wanted it because they
understand science and realized neither I nor
Joe Biden had anything to do with the vaccine.
Under Biden, left wingers still want the vaccine
because they understand science and realize that
neither Trump nor Biden had anything to do
with making the vaccine. But suddenly, Trump's
followers no longer want the vaccine because
they're morons. That's what it means. And Trump's
like, that means I'm great. Aren't I fantastic
as a result of that? Isn't that an amazing thing?
Trump then says that they he defeated ISIS in
Iran. I couldn't find any evidence of ISIS in
Iran, but Trump says he did it.
Speaker 5: We defy. We defeated
one hundred percent of the ISIS caliphate
in Iraq and Iran all over. But in Iraq,
we knocked out, by the way, we did Iran indirectly
a very big favor because they're not big fans of
ISIS, either through Syria. We knocked out 100
percent and we knocked out the leadership, and
Speaker 1: so I was not able to find
any evidence that ISIS was in Iran.
He's right that Iranians have been very
much opposed to ISIS for a long time,
but just kind of weird. We knocked out ISIS and
Iran. And then lastly, a completely unintelligible
moment where Trump says something about you
never used to hear the term mandate, but that
we're in great shape or something.
Speaker 5: Well, you know, we never
heard the term mandate, but people have to have
their freedoms and we should be in a great shape
between the people who get it. They should not
have to. If you get COVID or whatever you want
to call it, plenty of blame Wuhan virus, the
China virus, you can call it. We got plenty of
names, but well, you know, we know it.
Speaker 1: Were you able to understand
that? Because I certainly wasn't. But folks,
everything is smelling like this guy wants
to run again in 2024 and horribly, he
actually might have a shot at winning.